okay so he's he's trying he's trying to
grip to get something
going okay so when when he grips
i'm gonna leave this but he's he doesn't
really have forward energy
like you're uh kihon waza okay
so instead i can only leave it to my
other hand
that's that's the thing so i need it
it's not like i'm going here
okay so only to the other hand and then
jerk it down and you'll get this
position
then hold the head come in tight
and then inside control
his head
okay
hold his head this way underneath the
tricep okay
first get some pressure on him on your
knee knee to belly
if he's not moving then
find yourself
and when you're doing these movements
it's
the torque that you're getting so i have
the mechanical advantage on the
on the lever here okay and then i have
the superior engine because my whole
body's moving
but it's i'm using the shoulder
impingement so you should feel there's
there's not going to be any slack but
just keep
going into that shoulder impingement and
he'll fall
boom
so don't it's off
there's all that slack back in your
shoulder
here boom on there
[Music]
okay in this technique it's very popular
nowadays you turn the guy he stands back
off and then you do some goofy crap
okay but this is for law enforcement
purposes so it violates the marshall
principle is that
you don't check somebody and then
uncheck him to check him
because in real life you may not get
that second chance
so you don't take second chances so
won't
pop i keep this pin because
at least i have control so
i keep the whole pin trying to stand up
he
there's always a pressure on him try to
stand up throughout the ticket
do you see
when i'm when i'm doing the other one he
comes up he's up here the fight is back
on brother fire's back on okay
and you can't do that so you have to
keep the height checked
here get this to hold his head up
thread down
don't uncheck them to check them that
makes no martial sense at all
okay let's go
boom
[Music]
his body goes down you protect his head
move out of the way
and you find flat control
so of course this is this technique
but you can't do that you'll break his
head
push stay connected
you'll get the gift wrapped a lot
because the arm drag put it in place
already
so look for it
it's right here
okay
just like that last technique so when
you come here it's very common
you uncheck the guy whom
you're just dreaming okay so same thing
when you're uh doing this technique the
last one looks like you're pulling them
backward you're accelerating the back
he's allowed me keep going forward and i
just i stopped his head
i stuff his head do you see
he's not going backwards so you can see
his feet kick
all four going backwards to me as like
so if you're here and you're trying to
protect this guy you're like oh you saw
a boss when you start bringing him
backwards
and you're going to get over accelerated
you're going to lose his head so
instead he goes forward you see
forward
just keep the hips going forward
okay